[Musica]
freeze è una parola inglese che vuol
dire ste fermo sta immobile non ti
muovere
per me è importante questa parola perché
è legata al risveglio fatti io voglio
parlare del risveglio come un qualcosa
che è necessario per distoglierci da
questa inerzia da questo non muoverci
ed è importante muoverci in questo
momento perché ci aspetta un futuro
diverso da quello che immaginiamo con
dei rischi è il movimento è fondamentale
affinché questi rischi possano essere
riconsiderati in forma positiva
ovviamente ne parlo dal mio punto di
vista io sono un architetto e quindi
devo capire qual è il mio ruolo come
architetto all'interno di questo
cambiamento e di come posso intervenire
soprattutto che importanza l'architetto
l'architettura all'interno di questo
contesto il contesto di cui stiamo
parlando il contesto del climate change
un cambiamento che implica non il fatto
che ci troveremo di fronte uno scenario
nuovo diverso ma che questo scenario
cambierà continuamente secondo per
secondo
per i prossimi centinaia forse migliaia
di anni cosa c'entra l'architettura ogni
volta che parlo di questo tema la
domanda è chi questo è un tema che
riguarda politici che riguarda i
decision makers che riguarda
probabilmente gli industriali le
politiche industriali e l'economia
ecco questo grafico che vedete dice che
la realtà non sta proprio così il ruolo
degli architetti fondamentale se
parliamo in termini di co2 vedremo che
probabilmente anzi certamente le
emissioni di co2 in gran parte vengono
causate dalle costruzioni
se consideriamo anche il sistema di
trasporti e sommiamo questi due fattori
cioè consideriamo come la forma della
città interviene nel sistema dei
trasporti ci accorgeremo che la città di
per sé
la principale causa di emissioni co2
ecco che il ruolo dell'architetto
diventa importante se non determinante
in realtà noi sappiamo anche quali sono
gli ingredienti che dobbiamo utilizzare
per rispondere a questa necessità
la ricerca ci aiuta quindi sappiamo che
si tratta di città più resilienti nel
senso capaci di adattarsi a questo
mutamento e questo mutamento porta con
sé dei cambiamenti climatici estremi
quindi le città devono adattarsi a
questi cambiamenti climatici estremi
il secondo aspetto è la compattezza
dobbiamo aspettarci città sempre più
densamente popolate più compatte perché
il le disponibilità delle risorse è
sempre più limitate dipende da solo
produttivo mangiare la dimensione delle
città
maggiore sarà disponibilità di solo
produttivo questo mi porta una
conclusione sapendo che la popolazione
mondiale crescerà se non vogliamo
arrivare a quella che noi nel centro di
ricerca di posto non chiamiamo equazione
impossibile
dovremmo considerare un nuovo elemento
che è l'elemento fondamentale per il
risveglio e la creatività
ecco perché noi parliamo di radical
concept parliamo di visionarietà di
capacità di vedere il mondo con occhi
diversi
in realtà questo non vuol dire che sia
parliamo di un futuro e non dobbiamo più
rivolge al passato sappiamo che prima
della rivoluzione industriale in qualche
modo alcuni di questi modelli sono già
stati applicati venezia è chiaramente
una città radicale una città visionaria
ma potremmo rivolgersi anche ad altri
modelli come shimbun lo yemen una città
che in tutto e per tutto risponde
perfettamente alle nostre necessità
climatiche dell'area in cui sorge il
deserto una città ultra compatta che
resiste eventi eventi del deserto
dimenticato il deserto a questa
superficie superiore bianca con un'alta
albedo che consente una riduzione
drastica dell'italian jazz una cosa di
cui si parla spesso come se fosse un
problema non conosciuto dagli antichi
naturalmente anche questa idea dell
essere visionari non è una novità di per
se sappiamo che esiste un periodo
storico in cui la visionarietà è stata
determinante ed è stata determinante
proprio quel tipo di capacità di vedere
il mondo in modo radicale che proveniva
proprio da
mondo dell'architettura o dal mondo
dell'arte mi riferisco al rinascimento
che cosa che fa rinascimento con la
crisi climatica di oggi a che fare che
la crisi del trecento aveva
caratteristiche molto simili alla crisi
attuale una riduzione delle risorse una
popolazione che non era più in grado di
accedere a queste risorse
un cambiamento climatico di tendenza
opposta si trattava di una mini
glaciazione e terza non ultima la
problematica legata al fatto che una
malattia la peste nera era in qualche
modo la ragione che tutta la società
avrebbe dovuto cambiare in una forma
diversa avrebbe dovuto in qualche modo
rivoluzionare economia e società
questo importante perché è veramente i
primi il riferimento ai primi due
fattori abbastanza immediato riferimento
alla salute è altrettanto importante che
siamo immediato sappiamo che il climate
change sarà una delle cause principali
di malattie nei prossimi 20 anni
ecco che figure come leonardo visionari
cioè persone che sono capaci di vedere
il mondo con occhi diversi nuovi senza
la mappa mentale che ha condizionato noi
è fondamentale come facciamo oggi a fare
a coltivare questa capacità creativa che
ci porti a un risveglio di una mia idea
la media che nasce dal fatto che sono
anche un educatore questo si può fare
attraverso appunto l'educazione grazie
al fatto che i giovani gli studenti non
sono condizionati come noi dinosauri da
una visione del mondo che in qualche
modo è determinata dagli ultimi 100 anni
di storia
quindi noi il nostro lavoro è proprio di
cercare di instillare in loro la
capacità di essere creativi inventivi
anche radicali anche estremi vediamo qui
una serie di lavori fatti da studenti e
da collaboratori dei nel mio centro di
ricerca media hub che sono anche come
dire oltre che studenti dei veri e
propri ricercatori si tratta di liam
star wars in questo caso lui ipotizza
una città che viene rivoluzionata
dall'idea di eliminare completamente il
traffico automobilistico e di
riutilizzare il materiale
le autostrade per ricostituire un nuovo
tessuto urbano qui vediamo un esempio
della città di auckland e delle
conseguenze su questa città come gli
spazi destinati originariamente le
autostrade diventano dei parchi e delle
strutture utilizzabili da tutta la
popolazione della città
vediamo che il sistema si cerca di fare
utilizzo delle tecnologie più avanzate
come per esempio l'uso dei droni è la
cosiddetta il cosiddetto soir behavior
la capacità dei droni di muoversi a
chance e vediamo come la possibilità di
modificare anche la performance della
città diventa essenziale in questo
ragionamento
un altro esempio utilizzare la botanica
come strumento di rivoluzione della
città quindi sistemi ecologici che
nascono dalla modificazione genetica dei
vegetali oppure disegnare una città come
nel caso di nightbook iv ipotizzando che
la città deve essere insegnata non solo
sui flussi umani su quelli che sono i
movimenti degli uomini e le loro
necessità ma anche su quello delle api
che sono stati proprio oggi è stato
dichiarato il fatto che le api sono gli
animali più importanti sul nostro
pianeta
oppure possiamo utilizzare del materiale
cellulare di questo tipo possiamo capire
come si espande e quindi possiamo capire
quali sono le tendenze d come dire organ
di questi organismi di riassettarsi è
allo stesso tempo possiamo anche capire
come si può utilizzare direttamente
questo materiale come materiale per le
costruzioni in questo caso lo
utilizziamo come briciole come
possibilità di rendere più opache le
finestre controllandole sviluppo fino a
un estremo come questo disegnato da joey
quanche la trasformazione della città in
chiave totalmente organica
qui vediamo un progetto di michael
brewster bevin liang che riguarda la
possibilità di inserire l'automazione la
robotica nella città questa tecnologia
consente alla città di essere residente
nel senso che la capacità di adattamento
dipende appunto da questa capacità
questa dotazione robotica del della
città stessa
utilizziamo anche se non si tratta solo
di elaborazioni
speculative si tratta anche di
realizzare modelli che rispondono come
in questo caso utilizzando un arduino a
queste ipotesi di progetto fino all
ultima città che vorrei farvi vedere di
questa serie è una città sulla
nell'antartide condizioni estreme in
questo caso quello di cui stiamo
parlando e della possibilità di
utilizzare queste condizioni estreme
climatiche del nostro pianeta come delle
risorse ovviamente limitando il nostro
carbon footprint
tuttavia queste zone estreme producono
delle risorse che sono utilizzabili
qui vediamo esempi di questa di questo
sistema di città di questo sistema di
stazioni che sono una forma di
colonizzazione dell'antartide vediamo
che in qualche modo questo sistema è
molto simile a quello delle piattaforme
petrolifere ma il suo obiettivo è
completamente diverso è quello di
utilizzare per esempio i moti marini e
per esempio anche di ricreare un habitat
che sia favorevole alla relazione per
esempio tra uomo e animali vediamo come
in qualche modo si crea una relazione
con la fauna oceanica ora la domanda
quando io parlo di questi aspetti
generalmente quanto costa 4 costa
cambiare la domanda non è casuale perché
apparentemente una domanda retorica
in molti sostengono che cambiare
costerebbe moltissimo in fondo la nostra
società si basa sui combustibili fossili
e quello è come dire mantenere questa
condizione è certamente secondo molti
una condizione più favorevole dal punto
di vista economico
la risposta no e no non vuol dire che
cambiare costa meno e mantenere lo
status attuale non abbiamo tempo di
elaborare ma bastano pochi margini per
capire che così non è qui vediamo una
piattaforma petrolifera di ultima
generazione che va a scavare che va a
succhiare gli ultimi ultime gocce di
sangue del nostro pianeta dalle
profondità dell'oceano
con dei danni irreversibili alla
biodiversità la seconda obiezione è
lecita che vi ho fatto vedere
sono convinto se lo chiedesse a voi
forse più della metà del riterrebbero
che sono visioni distopiche e molti di
voi hanno già detto al proprio alla
persona vicino a si interessante forse
sperabilmente però non ci vorrei mai
vivere questo interessante perché
probabilmente è corretto non ci vorrei
mai vivere però cos'è la distopia se non
anche una condizione di non familiarità
con una certa condizione perché la
nostra condizione naturale è questa noi
non viviamo in case di campagna col
giardino viviamo in queste condizioni
l'ottanta per cento della popolazione
mondiale vivrà vive già oggi e vivrà in
queste condizioni probabilmente molto di
più o quella sinistra o quella destra 50
e 50
siamo sicuri che questa condizione non
sia una condizione distopica o
semplicemente la nostra sensazione che
l'ambiente che viviamo tutti i giorni
sia confortevole non sia solo legato
alla familiarità
in questo ambiente questa è una domanda
che a cui mi piacerebbe non dare una
risposta probabilmente avrete già capito
che quelle città in qualche modo ho
scelto degli esempi che cercano di dire
una cosa molto precisa cioè di stimolare
questa discussione per me sarebbe stato
facile far vedere a voi modelli molto
più rassicuranti per concludere vorrei
dire che per il risveglio è necessario
vedere come avrete capito dal mio punto
di vista il mondo da una prospettiva
completamente diversa io sono stato
fortunato per lavoro per ricerca potuto
trasferirmi nuova zelanda e questo ha
consentito mia consiglio di vedere il
mondo
in realtà proprio dal luogo più lontano
dall'italia dal mio paese e anche dalla
prospettiva più diversa dal sud del
pacifico e soprattutto di una fauna di
un contesto ambientale estremamente
diverso dal nostro
anche se si dice che duemila anni fa
anzi
prima dell'impero romano la nuova
zelanda somigliasse molto a quella che
era l'italia quello che mi colpisce
particolarmente della nuova zelanda e la
biodiversità e le caratteristiche della
fauna considerate che la nuova zelanda è
un luogo dove gli uomini non sono
arrivati fino al 1200 1300 i maori e nel
1700 siamo arrivati noi occidentali a
colonizzarlo quindi si è creato un un
habitat naturale estremamente diverso da
quello che conosciamo il capo secondo me
o capo è un animale che rappresenta un
po questa condizione
immaginate che il capo è un animale che
non vola
nonostante sia un pappagallo di grosse
dimensioni e quando deve riprodursi
sceglie uno delle decine di vulcani che
si trovano per esempio a auckland
centinaia forse migliaia in tutta la
nuova zelanda e va in cima a questa
collina una volta che in cima a questa
collina comincia a urlare questo suo
modo di attrarre hk la sua compagna che
per riprodursi a sua volta sale questa
collina
ora io rifletto sempre su questa
condizione perché io vengo dalla toscana
immagina un cinghiale che salga sul su
un colle e che urli non so quanto tempo
passerà prima che un cacciatore vada a
prepararsi la cena richiamato da questo
segnale un altro aspetto molto
interessante è che il capo a un certo
punto della sua vita ha trovato ha
incontrato l'uomo è quello che ha fatto
il capo quando incontrato l'uomo per la
prima volta è questa cosa qui ha fatto
freeze cioè si è fermato si è bloccato
sperando che il cacciatore non lo
riconoscesse che pensasse che il tea cup
fosse un albero o un una pietra
ecco immaginatevi il successo di questa
strategia i rischi che anche oggi
distinzione che anche oggi sta correndo
il cacao o il capo
ecco vorrei concludere dicendo vi questo
che in fondo il capo siamo noi oggi e
spero che questo sia una riflessione
voi condividerete con me
[Applauso]
[Musica]